listen falling living standards will be
the dominant political issue of the next
10 years absolutely there is no doubt
about that in my mind that will
absolutely be certain and people will be
demanding of politicians improve our
living standards but they don't know
what the cause of the Fall is and I'm
out here saying it's because of growing
in equality but there's a big voice out
there saying it's because of immigration
and because of foreigners and their
voice is currently much much louder than
my voice and if their voice is still
louder than my voice for the next 10
years it doesn't matter what is the
perfect TX
because we're not going to get any of
them